or voilà ce stade du journal et c'est
vraiment la fin nous voudrions élevé une
protestation qui a très peu de chances
d'être entendus car je ne sais pas trop
comment nous reçoit là haut je veux
parler du temps nous sommes très
précisément le 15 juin
à six jours de l'été et tout se détraque
un mois de mai pour y un début juin qui
promet mais depuis une semaine des
températures anormalement basses alors
aujourd'hui encore de la pluie sur la
région parisienne
des orages dans le sud et en montagne
bref ça ne va pas et on a envie de
savoir ce que nous réserve le week-end à
venir alors d'abord le constat laurent
broomhead et bien effectivement il ya
une période de boutons on a cru que
c'était le mois d'août est
malheureusement comme c'est normal au
mois de juin
il ya du mauvais temps a eu le mauvais
temps qui s'est déclenché au nord de
l'islande et qui tranquillement des sens
et va passer au nord de la france
pendant le week-end elle va amener des
perturbations successives en flot
continu alors concrètement qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pour demain alors demain
vendredi
demain la première vague c'est le
carrosse paris en ce moment elle va être
sur l'est depuis le jura le jura jusqu'à
l'alsace derrière ben y aura des
éclaircies belle pas mal et puis
derrière malheureusement ça c'est
ennuyeux il va y avoir une poussée d'une
deuxième vague de mauvais temps beaucoup
plus virulente et dans toute la journée
elle va envahir toute la france
attention ravale de vente pour les
plaisanciers dans le golfe de gascogne
ça signifie qu pour ceux qui partent en
week-end les biens à foix il faut
prendre les parapluies faut prendre les
imperméables et le samedi sera pas très
bon et nous aurons alors le samedi ça va
être guère plus gai le temps sera frais
sur toute la france les températures
vont encore baisser
il y aura des averses des orages sur à
peu près toute la france tout de même
une petite note d'optimiste sur le sud
sur la moitié sud quelques belles
éclaircies
en conclusion peut espérer pour dimanche
on peut espérer que les éclaircies
l'emporteront sur le mauvais temps enfin
tout état de cause notre mosquée al
azhar révélé un week-end vraiment
maussade gars n'avaient pas intérêt à
vous trompez car à partir d'aujourd'hui
vous êtes notre messieurs maintenant
monsieur météo tout court là ont décidé
de mettre davantage l'accent sur les
prévisions du temps et d'être si
possible meilleur que les autres
vous reviendrez nous voir donc avant
chaque week-end et puis à chaque fois
que l'actualité l'obligent et si
possible en tout cas le jeudi soir